finally your first time ever and your  first time this season perfect score how  does it feel oh yes I know  yes it would when Lin but like we have  not we have not got a ten from Linda's  whole entire season and when he kind of  took the hesitation like is he going to  do it is it and he tapped it up he  deserves this more than anybody I've  ever met he works so hard and especially  this week we just like every day was  like like grueling work and always so  much fun and surprisingly not stressful  but just so much work and he deserves it  more than anyone we just turn up and  down to do the best that we can and like  you said earlier I'm doing this for him  100%  you